welcome to this video playing a Patsy
Patsy from Switzerland and it's a sloth
defense let's see okay let's do them
let's go for the main line okay is six
yeah it should five is not really a line
I know too well okay but nevertheless
let's do that if you place the pot
Vinick was DC for me it would be a wild
a wild ride okay I Bishop e7 is of
course the most solid choice I'm trying
to play for Quincy to look you wan yeah
sometimes you can even go h4 in those
kind of positions but this is probably
not one of them
okay so night BTW 7s serve the
normal-looking move yeah one problem of
his setup is that is mixing yeah in a
way he is mixing systems and then it's
not clear that you want to play oh
that's a strange move if I've you
usually try to play a 6b five so a five
is a bit a bit strange
well you're never going to go to g6 not
with the bishop on d3 okay now that's
interesting should I go 95 mm hm I guess
so at the taxi six and it proved
prepares to play a form this type of um
formation is I guess quite okay for
white hmm what is there okay it's not
really clear to me what she was thinking
about that's hardly any other way to to
protect you see six okay so what should
I do now not easy should I exchange on
keep them keep the bishop on let's say
to go to g3 yeah maybe not sure sure
average shorter should exchange maybe
black can play at 5pm I know I conductor
can take the five that's a good position
okay so should I take on d5 or not hmm
yeah the Queen on c2 was not allowed
placed I need to get it over to the
kings island of the sea foam now that
was really quickly played very committee
decision let's see
yeah but here he's taking lots of time
that's funny I don't really have on any
alternative to to tell you to taking
okay so I was played this to continue
with the bishop to f5 or Bishop to b5
I'm not sure what is better okay me this
is in a position where you can easily
spend lots of time that tried to play
quickly yeah I can increase the pressure
even further 1d seven with quincy form
can I who isn't this just hey let's just
hang really black resigns yeah they
simply didn't didn't cover it Black is
under enormous pressure though I mean
what is there and let's say let's see
the comp to make it easier to evaluate
plus two yeah it's just a very passive
position to do something like that and
then the question is only how to how to
improve a computer wants to play Bishop
a for which is really a bit bizarre I
don't really understand the point of the
smooth hmm might be five if I don't
think so and have no idea what Bishop a4
is all about um the Dwight has probably
also some more human moves to to
continue rookie one yeah that's not
really
that's no not not much point to it yeah
maybe this wants to go here to increase
the pressure now not not sure really the
other question is if I may be my queen
is even better here to do a tech t5 yeah
it's hard to say it's very comfortable
for white but it does not feel like I
have a direct way to punish black what
is bishop if a for I really don't
understand the move what is this move
the computer also points out queen age
59 g4 yeah you should pay for very
mysterious okay thanks for watching